so we're back we're back from a vacation
it's been david pakman show summer
vacation for the last couple of weeks we
are back did you miss us
many people emailed me tweeted posted on
reddit they all of a sudden had a nearly
hour-and-a-half hole in their day if
they're members anyway and get the
monist bonus show many people say hey
I'm used to listening to the show or
watching through the show when I'm at
work or at the gym or commuting or
whatever and I'm flattered that the show
is a regular part of so many people's
days this is what I mean when we do
membership drives or patreon pushes and
I say hey imagine if the show were gone
if it wouldn't matter to you then okay
if it would then maybe the show is a
valuable enough thing to you that you
might consider making a small
contribution and we'll talk about our
respective vacations on the bonus show I
have stories ranging from car accidents
to all sorts of stuff I'll do my
vacation stories today Pat will do his
vacation stories tomorrow no shows for
two weeks but we actually had a lot of
things happening show related a lot of
thoughts and I've had some really
important discussions during the break
and we are now considering YouTube
effectively a lost cause okay so I'm not
gonna bore you with the background but
we've been dealing with this YouTube ad
pocalypse thing since March 31st 2017
YouTube ad revenue has basically
evaporated and I am now officially I've
been sort of waiting for revenue to
recover and trying to mitigate what's
been going on with membership or patreon
or whatever I am now saying this is it
we are considering YouTube a lost cause
the conversations I've had during the
break make it pretty clear to me that we
can no longer count on YouTube as a
funding source for our program so we're
gonna be restructuring a variety of
elements of the program and sort of how
we're gonna function operationally and
financially a lot of new things very
important things are gonna be rolled out
and I am now thinking of YouTube as
bonus money to the extent that it exists
and not really part of our key revenue
streams and a lot of these changes will
start over the next month
to different parts of the show long-form
videos that we've been dabbling with are
now going to become a more formal part
of the program the response to them has
been overwhelmingly positive
and some have been published to YouTube
over the vacation but we'll be running
on the broadcast show over the next
couple of weeks really good pieces on
classical liberalism and voter fraud
voter suppression political violence
socialism and we're also going to be
restructuring a lot of aspects of
membership and patreon on the membership
side we will be restarting supporter
only events supporter member only live
streams we are also going to be
launching $1 a trial membership which
will go a week and remember I believe
membership is so great that if people
tried it
most of them would stick with it so
we're gonna be looking at rolling out a
$1 one-week trial membership after which
you can either bail on the entire thing
or subscribe I believe most people will
subscribe and the audience has also
spoken on patreon rewards and goals
okay rewards and goals so we are in the
next again in the next three to four
weeks we will be instituting a number of
new patreon goals the current goal is
2,000 patrons and we've already got
goals set up for 3,000 and 4,000 patrons
for patreon only content but we're also
going to be loading up some rewards for
patrons and by popular demand we are
going to be having the bonus show
accessible to patrons at a certain level
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
we will have the full broadcast show
available to patrons at a certain
contribution level we are going to have
some supporter only monthly live streams
that will bring together members and
patrons we are going to have different
perks that will be available at
different levels of membership and
patreon so there's a lot of different
stuff that's going to be going on
tomorrow we've got a new membership
giveaway coming to us thanks to a viewer
named Patrick more on that tomorrow
we've got a couple new advertisers
coming on board so really a lot going on
and the the underlying reason is that
YouTube is basically done for us as a
revenue source the upside is a lot of
great stuff happening for you and
more about that upcoming in the next few
weeks